today we've got a bunch of new Apple
watch bands they recently released a
bunch of colors for springtime so I
picked out a few of my favorite colors
and here they are let's open these up
try them on and I'll do a little watch
band fashion show for you guys which one
am I going to open up first is the
question I've been so into the sport
loop bands it took me a while to get
into them because I was really into just
the regular sport band the first time
that I tried this and actually went to
hot yoga class but that I was like this
is amazing like it's not sticking to my
arm but I did mention this in a
different video that it does get pretty
disgusting so I just throw it in the
washer with my clothes and then I play
this fun game of where's my Apple watch
begin to put them to injury it's really
fun it's great you guys should dry it
all right I'm gonna open up the purple
one first because purple is one of my
favorite colors yeah this looks
incredible
the thing is with the gold sometimes
it's hard to find colors that look good
with it which is something that I
thought until I basically put every
single Apple watch band on and they all
looked really good so maybe it was just
something that I was thinking in my mind
have I sweated this thing into oblivion
what a nice compliment oh man there's
nothing like a fresh and clean Apple
watch band this looks really good I love
it so this is the lilac a sport loop
gosh I love the sport loops they're so
soft it almost doesn't even feel like
you're wearing a watch anymore I love my
Apple watch so much although I don't
know if this has happened to you guys
but I wear my Apple watch so tight that
like my arm is indented
I guess that's just a part of my body
now papayas for loop coming up next
don't look like papaya I mean there is
not a better name that they could have
come up with us actually maybe like
tangerine or Orange Crush or what is is
it like orange sherbert yummy I think I
like the lilac with a gold a little bit
better but this definitely makes a
statement like hello I am here I give
you're crossing the street or something
it's like a construction to kill her
orange doesn't thing that I definitely I
think where I'm going out with to the
club you're like hello hello ah oh I
don't go to the club
but if I did this is what I would wear
I'd probably wear this ripped sweatshirt
as well
papaya a sport loop looking good let's
have lunch I use it basically every day
I think almost every definitely had this
one on almost every day since I got it
next up we've got the spearmint sport
loop looking super minty I think the
myth might actually compliment
iPhone case the best it's the pink sand
it's the new charging case I'm so
excited for this one this one might be
my favorite I haven't even seen it yet
oh yeah
this looks good I do like the papaya but
I feel like this isn't gonna match that
many things these colors all look so
good together the grain looks really
good with the gold as well experiment in
I can't decide which one I like the most
I do think so far I like the experiment
I really like the lilac this is a
problem who are you wearing I wearing
spearmint support loop so right now I'm
gonna be wearing Apple watch 40
millimeter lilac modern buckle there are
these little tabs all over my office
this is gonna be my first stainless
steel buckle I've never had them before
this looks so good why am I not one of
these before
I just feel like the like that little
mermaid song like a whole new world
no that's Aladdin I was thinking of
little mermaid when she sings the song
gadgets and gizmos a-plenty I think I've
got whosits and whatsits galore this
Apple watch band has just opened up my
eyes like I saw the sign that's a sea
bass jeez why have you guys been keeping
the secret for me why has no one told me
that modern buckle is freaking fantastic
maybe I'd wear this to the club
I gotta go to the club what do they have
a gold one these are a lot of questions
that I need to have answered this just
really did open up my eyes to a whole
other look of a balázs bands now you
come here look I have something for you
here's it no moving on we have two more
but even if you used my knife this
entire video there's something wrong
with me
spearmint is such a good color yeah
ready on this beautiful Easter colors I
should go sit on the Easter Bunny's lab
which color should I wear when I go sit
on his lap let me know in the comments
below this theorem it looks great with a
gold we've got one more Jenna this is
beautiful wait that purple one have you
seen the modern buckle
no this isn't lovely lavender I know
it's lilac I like lilac that the color
no this is the last one that we have to
try on this is papaya vision watch how
do I not have a watch you have no I have
a gold Q that's unusable okay oh so if
there's no need that looks better on my
watch you can just toss them this way do
you think you like your watch better or
your iPhone that's a dumb question that
is a dumb question I need them both to
find each other okay this is what I'll
hear all the time and that interesting
just 100% guaranteed you that is during
like winter months or whatever it's like
uggs season I always forget and I put my
phone in my finger boot I do that too I
have to find it hey are these in my
pocket I'm like where's my phone I'm
like aw it's on me that looks nice I
like that with the goal is I would say
the biggest surprise on all of these is
how much I loved the modern buckles okay
you sure you very fashionable I've never
had one of these before
I only have a watches that I've had over
the years and for however long they've
had the better than new well the colors
new but the modern buckle style is not
new I like it it's really thin
I know wow give me this let me show you
yes I've got to show you this you're
gonna be I really like being shocked
this is the color of my room at home
that's how much I like that color today
yeah you can't wear all of these at the
same time oh no challenge accepted
I think I might have enough Apple
watches to make it happen Oh weird locks
okay why am I here I don't know I like
this I think I'm wearing this at dinner
tonight I'm like sure have to Salman
heard this Ahmad color color
what color what color do you want give
me that one experiment Sport lab looks
Wow hello well so spring ball they want
their fashion back I'll have the pasta
probably have a ravioli is rice to start
no did you look at the menu no no I
didn't either there baby no dinner
tonight
if you it's a very picky eater and every
time I did look at the menu I did not
choose the restaurant dinner anyway
thanks this is my know we keep each
other's things for so long that it's
just like this is mine now yeah like
that one shirt that I think she actually
took back I did take it back are you
have like a year and a half I believe in
longer mine well Jenna thank you so much
for joining oh that's great to see you
yes
and then you haven't been here all day
or anything no I was upstairs first time
I saw you while surprised this is for me
now cool thank well I know what you guys
think of this new little area we've been
doing some some rearranging a lot of
things happening a lot of society since
I don't blog anymore it's like you guys
don't even know me you're not missing
much I know her you know the same thing
I mean I sit around eat play video games
play with a dog hike you got five more I
do other secret activities i vlog so you
can come to my channel go check on Jenna
Sherlock's not as much I'll be cool
bye bye I'm gonna keep this look up what
looks a bit sport modern man modern
buckle Wow
thousand greatest I'm tired
[Music]